[Aplausos]
cuando tenía 11 años empecé a lavarme
las manos con lejía concienzudamente
hasta hacerla sangrar
con 14 me costaba seguir la lección en
el instituto y solía traspasar el papel
que tanto repasar lo que acaba de
escribir a los 18 me resultaba imposible
hablar con alguien sin repetir mis
propias palabras y caminaba por la calle
evitando a toda costa pisadas las rayas
del pavimento
estos y otros comportamientos pueden ser
normales entre el aproximadamente millón
de españoles que sufren trastorno
obsesivo compulsivo
y yo soy uno de ellos
el trastorno obsesivo compulsivo toc es
un trastorno de ansiedad que se
caracteriza principalmente por dos
síntomas el primero son los pensamientos
recurrentes que el propio individuo
reconoce como intrusivos y sin ningún
sentido son las llamadas obsesiones en
mi caso una muy común era la convicción
de que algo horrible le iba a ocurrir a
mi familia de forma inminente
estos pensamientos crean una ansiedad
una culpa y un pánico tales que conducen
casi irrevocablemente al segundo
componente la compulsión que no es sino
la conducta repetitiva que el individuo
emplea para tratar de neutralizar de
algún modo el malestar que las
obsesiones provocan
para entendernos en mi caso yo repetía
chequeaba la baba para quedarme
tranquilo de que si lo hacía
correctamente entonces mi familia
estaría a salvo era así de simple y así
de complejo obsesión compulsión
como es lógico el 'top puede tener un
impacto muy alto en la vida de una
persona por lo que la organización
mundial de la salud lo incluye entre las
siete enfermedades psiquiátricas más
discapacitantes
hoy
estoy aquí para decir que el trastorno
obsesivo-compulsivo es una parte de mí
que no me avergüenzo
me ha costado muchos años ser capaz de
decir esto
todos estamos educados para sentir
vergüenza cuando hablamos de
enfermedades mentales y el 'top puede
esconderse por lo que puede estar
sufriendo lo a alguien muy cercano a
nosotros sin que lo sepamos nunca
ignorarlo no hablar de ello
o no saber qué es exactamente mirar
hacia otro lado aún cuando nuestras
intenciones no sean malas conduce al
tabú al aislamiento y como consecuencia
última a la falta de un diagnóstico y de
las herramientas necesarias para superar
estas dificultades la culpa y la
vergüenza asociadas al 'top hacen que en
españa un paciente con trastorno
obsesivo compulsivo tarde de media más
de 7 años en pedir ayuda profesional
siete años innecesarios de sufrimiento
en soledad por miedo a hablar y ser
rechazado
hay una buena noticia que es que con el
tratamiento adecuado las tasas de
mejoría clínica significativa se
encuentran en torno al 80 por ciento es
posible vivir y ser feliz pareciendo top
pero para eso tenemos que hablar más y
mejor de ello debemos dar a conocer sus
síntomas y la eficacia de su tratamiento
debemos evitar que se confunda con una
cómica excentricidad o que pase a ser
uno más de esos comportamientos
cómodamente catalogados como estar loco
hoy hablo por primera vez en público
pero pueden estar seguros de que no será
la última y no olviden que juego con
ventaja cuando el obsesivo compulsivo
como yo se propone conseguir algo
puede llegar a ser verdaderamente
existente muchas gracias